the right-hander jorge lopez on the
mountain lopez started the year as a
long reliever for the orioles but is
getting an opportunity to make his
second start aaron hicks will lead off
the game exits the ground ball to third
in the drawn in rio ruiz is there to
throw out kicks at first here is luke
hoyt lloyd swings and slams one good
left ryan mount castle back into his
left makes the catch two down for brett
gardner there's a ground ball flatly to
second and velenka he throws to first
and it's a one two three inning for
jorge lopez david garcia gonna get start
number two in the big leagues and if it
was anything like stark number one wow
watch out david garcia will throw to
cedric mullins is hit on the ground
picked up by garcia knocked it down
throws to first and there's one away so
it came
back from 3-0 now here is dj stewart
strike three stewart down looking here's
nunes struck him out swinging fastball
up
so a very good first inning for davey
one two three including two strikeouts
orioles pick up their first hit against
davey garcia here's ryan mount castle he
swings and powers one deep left field
headed back is gardner forget about it
ryan meltcastle sends one out and the
orioles take a two to nothing lead and
that is the first damage ever against
davy garcia
he accused this one out to the mound
garcia issues handling it
and ruiz is safe that'll be an e1
there's pat belaka lined and one hop
wade fields goes the second one on to
first
not in time vallejka beat it out one on
one out batteries dilson herrera swing
and a miss runner goes throw to second
it's a strike em out throw him out
double play good throw by crackling to
go to the third tyler wade leads off
against jorge lopez crown ball through
for basic so wade for the lead off
single well he's the threat to run
here's estrada
locked nicely by severino
and he throws it into center field as
wade will now go to third speed it does
certain things ground ball is short
wade will score easily the throw to
first
they get astratus or an rbi for him the
yankees are on the board is 2-1 orioles
and baltimore has first and second with
one man out and the hitter good hitter
renato nunez struck him out swinging
fastball up and in great spot you don't
really have to throw
95-96 if you can locate and this young
man can locate so too there's severino
swung on hit in the air to deep center
hicks going back on the track he makes
the catch to end the enemy two down they
hold gardner on at first and a 2-1 lead
miguel andujar stands in ground ball to
third ruiz
and he throws it past herrera gardner
will go to third as and duhar moves to
second
that's gonna be an e5 and it's gonna
prolong the inning here's eric kratz
base hit could give the yankees the lead
line drive it's a base hit to left field
gardner scores and duhar scores and the
veteran eric kratz picks up his son
davey garcia and gives him back the lead
three to two well how big is that
throwing everything and there's first
and second with two men out and that
will bring up velasquez brighton ball is
grounded to first
and ford flips to davy garcia to end the
inning
so the play goes 3-1
davy garcia is going to try to pick up
his first big league victory he's got to
get through this inning without allowing
a run swing and a miss
nunez down on strikes
strikeout number six and if davey gets
one more out at least he'll qualify for
the win line drive in the left severino
with a base knock do they allow garcia
to get this final out no they don't and
now he's going to go to the bullpen so
another good performance by davey garcia
he leaves with the he's up 3-2 but the
orioles threatening but he turns it over
to his fellow rookie clark schmidt who
is making his major league debut there
are two outs runners at first and second
what an odd time to bring in schmidt he
faces ryan mount castle hits this one
into center field for a base knock rbi
base knock for ryan mount castle we're
tied at three here's ruiz here's a swing
and a ground ball left side it's through
they send severino around orioles take
the lead so a couple of hits off clock
schmidt we're not blaming schmidt that's
some place
to put him in balaka
nestles it in fair down the line mount
castle scores two more for the orioles
with a big bottom of the fifth they take
a 6-3 lead and the orioles are one out
away from ending this win streak forever
at 19 for the yankees against the
orioles swinging a ground ball into the
ship the second baseman valley on the
left side fields throws to first and the
streak is over nobody i mean nobody
beats the baltimore orioles 20 times in
a row